the three-year-old
Please.
[Music]
Don't make me.
I want to
be my
Let me sleep. Let
me in my
life. Terrible.
Hello. Oh, good. It's fun. Hi, welcome
everybody. My name is Valerie. My
pronouns are she, her. Um, we've got a
lot of exciting things happening at the
table. Uh, when the QR code pops up
there on the screen, you'll be able to,
if you scan that, you'll be able to see
a lot of the exciting things we have
going on. We've got the wheelchair ramp
project going on. Um, our Dallas Pride
booth, there's signups there as well.
and also our summer kids day. All of
that information can be found by
scanning the QR code and clicking on the
appropriate links so you can see the
dates, times, and sign
up. It is the first Sunday of the month,
so we are going to be at Hat Creek um
here in Saxi off Highway 78. We'll be
there immediately following this
service. So, we hope to see everyone
there. Also, if you are feeling anxious
about being in a church setting, you're
part of the disability community, or
you're just feeling a little bit extra
fidgety today, we have some an
accessibility bucket right over here on
this table. There's noise cancelling
headphones, fidgets, stuff to draw with.
So, you can go over there and use any of
those things if you'd like at any point
during the service. We just ask that you
return them at the end of service.
These candles that you see on either
side of me are a sign of the presence of
Christ among us, fully divine and fully
human. Now we exit the kingdom of
noise, of hurry, of productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of
silence,
stillness and
simplicity. Sacred
space, a place for prayer, worship and
adoration. A place to behold
Christ, revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation. Allow the unforced rhythms of
grace to find you, to mend your heart.
Maybe we all come
[Music]
home. Thanks, Val. If you guys would
stand with us, we're going to sing some
songs together tonight. And I just
encourage you to listen to the words as
we sing. Um make them a prayer over your
life, over our community, over this
city. Um, but let's engage this time not
just as a a moment to sing, but as a
moment to worship a God who's for us, a
God who is with us, and who loves
[Music]
us, rising With the rising of the
sun,
goodness rushing
in my
lungs. Your
faithfulness is here and now.
The
evidence is all
around. I bless your
name. I give you
praise. Today is a day for
singing. Awake my soul. Come on and
praise the
Lord. Today is the day for singing.
Oh my
soul,
praise the
Lord.
Oh my
soul, today is a day for
singing. A new
song is welling up deep inside of me.
[Music]
Hallelujah. Have been
redeemed. Have been
redeemed. I bless your
name. I give you
praise. Today is a day for
[Music]
singing. Awake my soul. Come on and
praise the
Lord. Today is a day for
[Music]
singing.
Oh my
soul to
praise the
Lord.
Oh my
soul, today is a day for singing.
Today, today is a day for
[Music]
singing. From the valley to the
mountain, the desert to the
fountain. Oh, I will praise
you. From the morning to the evening, as
long as I am
breathing, a day for
singing from the valley to the mountain,
the desert to the fountain.
Oh, I will praise
you from the morning to the evening as
long as I am breathing. Today is a day
for
singing. Today is a day for singing.
Today,
today is a day for singing.
I bless your
name. I give you
praise. Today is a day for
singing. Awake my soul. Come on and
praise the
Lord. Today is a day for
singing. Oh my soul.
Oh my
soul. Praise the
Lord.
Oh my
soul, today is a day for singing.
soul to the
mountain to the mountain.
[Music]
Today is a day for
singing. Today is a day for singing. One
more time.
[Music]
Today is a day for singing.
All right, you kiddos are dismissed to
go to your
classes. Thank you kids ministry
team for loving on them
tonight. Y'all have fun.
[Music]
And as they leave, we're going to
transition into a time that we call
prayers of the people. Um, if you're new
here tonight, it's just a moment that we
pause to lift up the things that we
carry into this space. Um, we each carry
in a different story, a different past,
a different present. And whatever you're
carrying on your heart, we believe is
important. And we want to lift that up
together and carry that with you. Um, so
you guys can follow along on the
screens. We'll read the parts in red
aloud together and then we'll pause in
the middle for you to speak out a name
or a situation that's on your heart
tonight. Would you guys join
me for this city of Saxi, Texas, and for
every city and community and all who
live in them? We pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick.
For the widow and the orphan, for the
injured and the suffering. We pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence. Amen.
[Music]
Matthew 18 says, "What do you think if a
man owns a hundred sheep and one of them
wanders away? Will he not leave the 99
on the hills and go and look for the one
that wandered off? And if he finds it, I
tell you, he's happier about that one
sheep than about the 99 that didn't
wander off. In the same way, your father
in heaven is not willing that any one of
these little ones should be
[Music]
lost.
Before I
spoke, you were singing over
me. You have been so so
good to
me. I took a breath. You breathed your
life in me.
[Music]
You have so
kind to
me. Oh, the
overwhelming
neverending reckless love of
God. Oh, it chases me down. But still I
am found. Leaves the
99. I couldn't earn it and I don't
deserve it. Still you give yourself
away. Oh the
overwhelming
neverending reckless love of God.
[Music]
When I was your fault, still you look
for me.
[Music]
You have been so so
good to
[Music]
me. When I felt no worth, you paid it
all for
me. You have been so so kind to me.
Oh, the
overwhelming
neverending reckless love of
God. Oh, it chases me down till I'm
found. Leaves the
night and I couldn't hurt it and I don't
deserve it. Still you give yourself
away. Oh, the
overwhelming never
ending love of God.
[Music]
There's no shadow you won't light up.
Mountain you won't climb up coming after
me.
There's no wall you won't kick down you
won't tear down. Coming after me.
There's no shadow you won't light up.
Mountain you won't climb up. Coming
after me.
[Music]
There's no wall you won't kick down. You
won't tear down. Coming after me.
There's no shadow you won't light up.
Mountain you won't climb up. Coming
after
me. No wall you won't get down. Light
you won't tear down. Coming after me.
Oh no shadow you won't light up.
Mountain you won't climb up. Coming
after me.
through the wall. You won't kick down by
you won't tear down coming after
me. Oh, the
overwhelming
evering reckless love of
God. Oh, it chases me down right till
I'm found. Leaves the night.
I couldn't earn it and I don't deserve
it. Still you give yourself
away. Oh, the
overwhelming,
neverending, reckless love of God.
[Music]
There's no shadow you won't light up.
Mountain you won't climb up coming after
me. There's no wall you won't kick down.
lie you out coming after
me. No
shadow, no shadow you won't light up.
No wall you won't kick down.
You coming after
me, God of
creation, there at the star before the
beginning of
[Music]
time with no point of
reference. You spoke to the dark and
fleshed out the wonder of
life. And as you
speak, a 100 billion galaxies are born.
In the vapor of your breath, the planet
is for
if the stars were made to worship. So
light.
I can see your heart and everything
you've made.
Every burning
star of
grace. If creation sings, your praise is
so alive.
[Music]
God of your
promise, you don't speak in vain. No
syllable empty.
[Music]
Once you
expen all nature and science follow the
sound of your voice.
And as you speak,
a 100 billion creatures catch your
breath.
[Music]
Evolving in pursuit of what you say.
If it all reveals your nature, so
alive. I can see your heart in
everything you say.
Every painted sky can of your grace.
If creation still obeys you, so alive.
[Music]
So,
so if the stars were made to worship, so
were I.
If the mountains bow in red, so will
I. If the oions roar your greatness, so
will
I. For if
everything exists to lift you high, so
will I. If the wind goes where you said,
you're so
alive. If the rocks cry out in silence,
so
alive. If the sun of all our praises
still
shine, you will sing again a h 100
million times.
[Music]
Oh, God of
salvation. You chased down my heart
through all of my failure in pride.
on the hill. You
ced the light of the world abandoned in
darkness to
die. And as you
speak, a 100 billion failures
[Music]
disappear. Will you lost your life so I
can find it
here? If you left the grave behind you,
so
alive. I can see your heart in
everything you've done.
[Music]
Every part design and work of our call.
If you gladly chose surrender, so will
I. I can see your heart in a million
different ways.
Every precious one child you die to
save.
If you gave me life to love and so
[Music]
alive like you would again 100 billion
times but when measured could amount to
your
desire. You're the one who never leaves
the one behind.
[Music]
Scott says, "I will never leave you or
forsake you."
And if you are here tonight feeling
alone, feeling lost or far from
home, the spirit of God says, "I see
you. I'm with
you. I love you.
because he doesn't abandon the work of
his
hand. He doesn't leave his children out
on the
streets. Our God is a God of
love. She calls us in
There's always room at her
table. Thank you for walking with us,
God.
Thank you for not giving up on
us, for never turning your
back, for never distancing yourself from
us. God, would we lean into your love?
Would we learn to listen to your
voice? Would we follow your guidance?
Would we be like sheep who know the
sound of the
shepherd and trust that he will come and
find
us. We love you.
We look for you
tonight. We listen for your voice. Would
you speak to us? Would you speak to our
hearts? Would you draw us close to your
heart in Jesus
name?
Amen. Thank you guys for worshiping
together with us. Would you um turn to
the people beside you and say, "The
peace of Christ be with you."
Well, grace and peace. It is so good to
be with you all and uh I see some faces
I haven't seen in a little while and
that makes me very happy. So, um yeah,
welcome, welcome to the table. My name
is Brett. I'm the pastor here and it's
just a joy, a joy to to be with you all
in this space and um also a joy to
welcome those joining us
online. Love you all lots. You're not
forgotten. Uh don't forget to get your
communion elements for later in the
service. You can participate in that
time with us. So, um, yeah, but
especially, um, anyone here tonight
who's new, um, we're really, really glad
that you're here. So, we are, um, oh,
and also, happy Pride Month is I need to
mention that. Happy Pride. Yes, June
1st. Like, we it's like Sunday felt
right on it. So, it's like, hey, it's
official, like kicked off. Um, so yeah,
really, really cool. Obviously, for us
as a community, that's um man, that's a
it's a soft place in our heart for the
the LGBTQ um plus community. And yeah,
so if you're in that community, we love
you. We support you. We're standing with
you. So um so we are we're in a u in a
series right now. I think this is part
four in our series titled Enchanted. Uh
reclaiming sacred ground in a
disenchanted world. And uh kind of what
we're we've been sort of walking through
is that we live in this um kind of
increasingly a a secular kind of society
that in ways I mean at one level you
could say sort of trying to move away
from God, religion, you know, all that.
Um at another level it's weird. We're
sort of I would say almost more uh
transitioning our religious allegiances
to other things. you know, uh, the
nation state that's making a comeback as
a sort of a a uh, sort of a source of
religious meaning, right? And then you
sort of slap a Jesus hood ornament on
that and then you know you know
Christian nationalism and uh so whether
it's you know that even science we
talked I guess a few weeks back about
kind of the way science goes from like
sort of lowercase s science to like
capital s sc sort of scientism and it's
like this whole story and explanation of
everything and you know um and people
kind of give that a certain religious
fervor and such and so uh yeah so with
that kind of move towards the the
secular uh in ways part Part of what's
happened is a kind of disenchantment
where uh you know as sort of God as like
that which is above us beyond us and
also intimately acquainted to us but
still above and beyond us as this song
beautifully kind of captured. You know
that sense of kind of uh the mystery of
all things you know the sacredness that
that we kind of here are somehow
participating and connected you know to
all of that. that's not something it's
not just God's out there somewhere gone,
but that we're connected, you know, that
that that sense of that kind of
sacredness and that depth dimension of
life that starts to get kind of drained
away in the the modern world. And a lot
of times once you lose um God that
that's some of what starts to to go. So,
um, in essence, what we're kind of doing
in this series is just touching on
various topics and kind of trying to
rethink them from a Christian
standpoint, kind of reinfuse them,
re-enchant them, so to speak. U, so
we're we've just kind of been a little
bit all over the place. And, uh, tonight
is this is a topic I don't know if I've
ever directly spoken of this, uh, but
the title of my message is treehugging
Christians and a little eco theology for
you tonight. ecological theology and uh
we have two primary scriptures tonight
both of them from the book of Psalms.
The first is Psalm chapter 104:es 24-28
which reads how many are your works Lord
in wisdom you made them all. The earth
is full of your creatures. There is the
sea vast and spacious teeming with
creatures beyond number. Living things
both large and small. There the ships go
to and fro and Leviathan which you form
to frolic there. Leviathan is sort of
like this mythical like sea monster kind
of creature you know I mean even for us
still the ocean is like tremendous
mystery. We don't we don't know what's
lurking way down there and we can't get
things that that deep. Uh continues
verse 27 all creatures look to you and
give them their and you uh look to you
to give them their food at the proper
time. When you give it to them they
gather it up. When you open your hand,
you're satisfied with good
things. Second is Psalm chapter 139
7-10. Where can I go from your spirit?
Where can I flee from your presence? If
I go up to the heavens, you are there.
If I make my bed in the depths, you're
there. If I rise on the wings of the
dawn, if I settle on the very far side
of the sea, even there your hand will
guide me. your right hand will hold me
fast. So our view of
creation of I mean really all that is
right of of oceans and rivers and trees
and fields and rocks and flowers and
fishes and humans and suns and moon and
you know all of it. Uh all of that is
deeply rooted, you might say, in how we
how we kind of imagine or how we
understand God's relationship to the
world to be.
So a well and that view of how we how we
imagine that has shifted quite
dramatically over time. So like for
example in the modern world this is very
much this part at least in keeping with
our series you know we're very with a
with the rise of technology we're quite
prone to think in terms of the metaphor
of
machine you know we love that like
that's just it almost a second like we
do that we don't even realize we're
doing it um it's just how we think right
partly because machines are everywhere
you know it's like part of the culture
part of our just everyday life. And so
we start to kind of think in
machine-like ways. And then we kind of
project that out onto the world. And you
can see where this went in terms of kind
of, you know, the way we imagine
creation and such is what do we do? We
start to imagine it as a vast
what machine, right? And and it's this
is and then even things like animals we
start to think of in a little bit more
depersonalized kind of machine like
ways. And uh this is some of this
becomes uh well it kind of starts
shifting towards what we'll um get into
this in a moment but kind of um what's
known as
dism which is the idea
that God kind of creates the world but
then
like leaves it you know kind of somewhat
abandons it almost like the way a a
clock maker might sort of make the clock
and then kind of leave the clock to just
do its thing, you know. And honestly,
like this view has very much kind of uh
infiltrated, you might say, the
imagination of Christians as well,
right? Like I think a lot of us kind of
by default are quite deistic if we're,
you know, completely honest in terms of
just how we imagine God and God's
relationship to the world. like God's
kind of made things and then sort of set
it up. It's running nature, you know,
which again is another little shift
where it's no longer creation but like
nature, you know, now nature's just kind
of it's doing its thing and then God's
kind of off and God sends Jesus though
to like help a little bit but then you
know Jesus left and so it's sort of and
you can see this sense of um kind of
separation. So,
uh, how how did we, you know, kind of
get to this point? Um, that's some of
what in the first part of this sermon I
want to I want to talk through a little
bit is sort of different ways to imagine
this God kind of what we might call God
worlds or God creation kind of
relationship. And, uh, and kind of to
that end, I have three kind of images. I
should mention though these I grabbed
these images from a wonderful blog post
written by um, Richard Beck. He's
talking about the theology of a guy
named Sergius Bulgakov and that's kind
of the post. Um but these images he kind
of outlined these. So this first part of
my sermon I will admit is like very it's
almost plagiaristic you know like I'm
really drawn from Richard Beck here. Um
then the other stuff will be more for
me. But um I love these images because I
thought oo this brings such clarity to
our topic tonight. So
um okay so h how do we kind of
understand the God world relationship? I
think it's most Christians I think
believe it's something like this. So
let's go to this first one. Right? So
there's God and then God
creates you know the world or creation
or
cosmos, right? That seems pretty
intuitive like yeah. Okay. That's pretty
much
it. Oh no. Oh no. No. No. Wait. Do you
you like this? You think this is good?
You know, sorry I'm trying to get a
little cheeky, but I think I think we
kind of default to this. It has some
problems though. For one, you can see
where right there's this sense of
separateness right where it's sort of
like God creates this thing other than
God and that's like the world that's
creation that's cosmos that's you know
and that's kind of over there. Now the
upside to that is the thing I mentioned
earlier about transcendence. It is true
that Christians want to think in this
way where God is sort of more than above
beyond world or creation. Um the problem
here is the we start to imagine the
world again a little bit. This lends
itself to
disming in terms of we're on our own.
God kind of set this world running and
now it's just it's going and boy I hope
it I hope it goes good and I hope God
occasionally well even the way you think
of like miracles is like okay but
sometimes God does a miracle God like
jumps in intervenes meddles a little
bit. It's like, okay, I'm going to
suspend the laws of
nature, right? Can you see where this is
going? Like, okay, and now I'm going to
I'm going to do a thing. Okay, now I'm
back out. I'm back. All right, now it's
now it's it's, you know, it'll just play
out like normal. Okay, wait. I need to
intervene again. And let me do a little
thing here. Okay. Okay. No, I'm done.
No, now just you're on your own again.
You're on It's almost like a parent,
like an absentee parent that's like
mostly gone, but then occasionally comes
back home and it's like, "Oh, what are
you kids doing? Okay, we got to fix
this, fix that, fix it. Okay, goodbye.
You know, and then everything goes to
pot again, you know, and and sort of
this is this is sort of again what this
lends itself to. Also, another problem
with this kind of image is not just
about the world in a separate sense, but
God to we start to imagine God as a
thing which
exists. God, which is sort of a little
bit tricky because we would, you know,
this is often a question. Do you believe
God exists? Do you believe in the
existence of God? You know, but but if
you think of that, like to get a little
philosophical with you, a little little
tricky, like if you think of to
exist is sort of to stand out, to come
forth, to be a thing, you know, like
here I am. I exist, you know, and this
candle, look at it. It exist. It's sort
of standing out. This is a weird way
though to think of God, right? Oh, God
exists. As though, again, God's like a
thing. And this is where this kind of
lends itself. Start to sort of imagine
as I've talked about God as like a a
Zeuslike deity, right? Like imagine if
this face one morning just showed up in
the sky, humongous face and it's talking
and it's like I am God. And we're like,
"Oh my gosh, God exists." You
know that.
No, that's that's not how we think. God
is not a
being, a thing. Not even a really,
really, really, really, really big
thing. No, no, no. This is a category
sort of error. So, that's another
problem with this. It's almost like the
world exists and then God exists. You
can one way to think of it is you see
the blue circles, but then that light
blue background right to this slide.
Like it's almost like if God exists, if
God is a thing, even a really big thing,
amazing thing, incredible, the most
incredible thing you could imagine, you
know, well then what is it that sort of
gave rise? What is it that sustains,
suspends, upholds all that's existing,
including this really big God thing? You
see where the this gets squirly? Okay.
Um, so this is sort of the first slide.
Second one, second image, another way to
kind of imagine the God world
relationship is uh as God like
God/world. So here God is the world,
right? Or creation. Creation is God. So
you might think of it like um you know
this would be kind of classically known
as like pantheism where it's like the
tree the tree is God. You know the the
sun the sun is God. Uh you are God.
every you know everything this this
candle this chair everything it's all
God all that exists is God um the
problem here honestly it's sort of
similar to the first image where again
it starts to think of God as things
again even as a really big thing you
know if you're like well God is the
galaxy or God is every star or you know
what like you're you're still kind of
putting God in this box of like
existence of of a thing among just like
other things.
Um
so yeah also Christian orthodoxy really
wants to say God is both imminent to the
world which this slide does do a good
job of right you do get a sense of like
God in things and close and you know
that's the sort of upside to pantheism
downside is you miss any sort of
transcendence any sort of otherness or
God being able to um help guide or steer
or lead creation towards something like
that's Well, no. It's just kind of God's
collapsed into everything that is. All
right. So, that's pantheism. Um, the
third one, and this, of course, every
sermon, it's always the third one that's
the good one. You know, whatever.
Um, this one, I do think this is I think
this is a great way to understand it,
though I'm not completely sold on every
last I don't know all the language of
it, but I um I do think this is helpful.
So, this view, this isn't known as um
well, let's go to the next slide. This I
think is a better metaphor, a better way
to think of it. Right? So here you might
say God
is capital B
being. God is one metaphor some
theologians like is uh God is the
ground of all being. You get a sense
there of sort of God is the one
upholding sustaining
um but also kind of
saturating intimately acquainted with
everything. So for example, why does
this candle have being like why does it
continue to kind of exist there and not
just kind of you know I mean why does
anything why are how is any of this
working you know I mean how is it I'm
not just flying to pieces like how how
is does that make sense like it's a
weird thing we kind of take it all for
granted like well no of course
everything's real solid and just works
and you know we do but that's only
because it does like if it almost if you
think about it it's like why isn't
everything just crazy just crazy all the
time you know well There's a because uh
God is capital B being itself the ground
the source
uh and then God makes space within God's
very
self for
beings right you me the candle the chair
everything that exists that is one a few
metaphors think of it like maybe like
the way a mother has you know a womb
womb and the child in her womb is like
not exactly it's not her you know but
it's but it boy it's a tough thing to
sort of name exactly where like she ends
and the child begins so to speak you
know what I mean like it's it's really
tricky which is why of course
politically this is why this be throws
us just for a loop we don't even know
how to think of it um because it's like
who's who and what's what and you there
is a a sense there of such intimacy ing
such closeness, right? That that mother
is sort of in other words that um that
child in every way is dependent on
participating in the very life of that
mother. I think this is a much much much
better way to think of our connection to
God, right? How is it anything's
working? How is it we have life and
breath? How is how is this happening?
It's because of that we we are
um surrounded by saturated
by the spirit of God, the living God,
the God who is father, son, spirit. And
um yeah, we have being because God is
the source, the ground, the the
rootedness of of ourselves and all
things. Another metaphor might be um
like a sponge that's at the bottom of
the ocean, right? And the the sponge is
there. And if you said if you looked at
the sponge you're like that is ocean
you're like well I mean kind kind of not
not technically you know I mean sponge
has its own existence its own life its
own thing and yet it is utterly
dependent on its context on ocean and in
fact the sponge is sort of porous to the
ocean and
uh I think that's a better way to start
imagining like you right now are um in
the ocean of God, so to speak. You're
surrounded by, you're saturated by,
you're intimately acquainted with the
spirit of God always at all times. This,
by the way, this view is known as
panintheisms. So, not pantheism, but
panintheism. If you're want to do like
if you're nerdy, you want to do a little
research later, you could look that up,
all too of you. Um, no, I don't know.
Maybe there's more. I should be
optimistic. Half the room will do this.
I'm believing, you know, pan pantheism.
I mean, nerd out. Maybe not. Um, so,
okay. So, where does this kind of go in
terms of all this creation and like how
does this kind of tie back in? There's a
quote from Andrew Gley because I think
this last view, I think it lends itself
to a certain imagination for creation,
for the world, for ourselves and how we,
you know, relate to it. So, Andrew Gley
writes this, "Catholics live in an
enchanted world, a world of statues and
holy water, stained glass and vote of
candles, saints and religious medals,
rosary beads and holy pictures. Because
these Catholic paraphernalia are mere
hints of a deeper and more pervasive
sensibility which inclines Catholics to
see the holy lurking in
creation. As Catholics, we find our
houses and world haunted by a sense that
the objects, the events, and the persons
of daily life are revelations of
grace. I think that's really beautifully
put. uh the holy lurking in creation. I
love that. Right. Where there's a sense
not just it's not quite pantheism,
right? In the sense of God is that or
God is that or it's not quite there, but
it's but it's also not well that thing's
separate from God. That thing's cut off
from God. That's distant from God.
That's, you know, no, no, no. There's a
there's something in the depths of you
and all things where God is. I mean,
otherwise it wouldn't even have
existence. wouldn't be except that God
wills it to be in every moment. I just
think of that like God wills the why is
the world here right now? Because God
willed it to be right now. Why do you
have another
breath? Because God wills you to have
another breath. I mean, that's how
intimately acquainted God is to us. So,
this is um I think the word this is kind
of leading us to that I really like is
the word
sacramental. might be a new theological
word for you, but um I I like I like
this I like this word. So sacramental to
give you kind of a definition um a
sacrament is anything that both points
to and participates in divine
mysteries. I it's a great way so and
well, let me finish that thought. It's a
great way to start to imagine
um you and really all things. The way
James K. Smith puts it is he says a
sacramental understanding holds that the
physical the material stuff of creation
and embodiment is the very means by
which God's grace meets us and gets a
hold of
us. This is why uh in Christianity we
have these things known as like the
sacraments. Every church has like its
own kind of list of like what are the
holy sacraments you know pretty much
every church though includes like for
example Eucharist or communion is a
sacrament or baptism a sacrament and one
thing to note about these is well
they're in this definition in the sense
of what is a sacrament doing it's this
very physical material thing that is
doing what it's participating in and
pointing to a divine mystery which is
why when we come to take communion we
kind of sense a certain reverence here a
certain holiness you know I mean it's
there's it's a special moment somehow
even though you say well but it's just
some bread and some wine just it's
normal but that's the whole idea right
is that that's getting back to that
first slide of like oh but it's separate
from God it's just it's just bread and
wine and birds and flowers and this and
that you know water oh water's plain and
boring and but a sacramental imagination
says,
"Oh, incredible." You know, like that's
where you start to get this kind of
infused sense of like God is here and
present even now, right? So, the point
of a sacrament isn't to kind of limit
you in some way or to say like now these
are the holy things.
everything else is just whats you know
it's just unholy just un no no hopefully
what it does is by learning to relate to
that sacrament in a kind
of way you know like God is
present what do you do it's like a
springboard it's like you start to
relate to all things all people with
that kind of reference all creation
right so the way we could put it is all
creation everyone everything that is is
sacramental all of it points to all that
participates in the divine. So, what I'm
kind of doing here, I'm giving you like
a framework to um start to shift our
view of creation. Can you see where I'm
kind of going with like treehugging
Christians and such, right? Because all
of a sudden creation, the
world, it's not this like cut off thing
from God like, oh, it's just nature and
or god forbid a vast machine like like
no, no, no. There's something really
beautiful and precious and holy here.
So, I want to kind of um wrap this up. I
want to give you like a few kind of
implications like things that kind of
land this plane so to speak. So, you're
like how does this what does this mean
though like for our lives and such. So,
um few implications. Number one, to be
ecologically friendly is not some fringe
view of leftist
ecoantheists, but actually the common
concern of all
Christians of of obviously this kind of
topic, so to speak, has gotten very
politicized, which is sad because then
it's sort of like depending on which
team you choose, you care about this or
not. It's a very strange kind of side
effect of American politics in general
where we tend to think in terms of the
camps, you know, not so much the topics
like, oh well this I'm here and this I'm
here and that I think this and you know,
we're very like I chose a team, my team
thinks this and this is what I care
about, you know, and then everything
else that's just silliness or you know,
whatever. Um, but creation care and all
like no, no, no, no. This is this
sacramental imagination like suddenly
all of this stuff matters, right? And um
I
think like yes of course and at some
level the world is fallen and imperfect
but still because like you know oceans
and rivers and birds and trees and all
that are participating in God. Well then
those things are holy and so their
future their existence their being it
matters. It matters like because again
kind of in Christian circles it tend to
be like well human beings
matter. We are made in the image of
God but we have been given dominion over
creation. And so somehow in that weirdly
instead of thinking of as stewards you
know we start to think of like I can do
with creation whatever I want you know
it's like what are you because again
it's almost like I'm connected to God
perhaps through the spirit or something.
you know, I'm connected to God. The rest
of this stuff, just animals, just
plants,
ju who cares, like that is a downright
um I think it's say just an uncchristian
kind of way of thinking of it. I really
think Christians, we should have the a
kind of sensitivity to the natural world
of like a poet and the openhearted
concern of an activist. I think that's
like should be pretty normal uh in for
us as Christians. Um second implication
of this kind of sacramental panintheist
uh view factory farming and other
degrading practices which treat animals
like machines are not in alignment with
the best of Christian
theology. Uh I I think for example in
ways even Christian theologians have had
to go back to like indigenous cultures
and such to try and recover some of our
own best thinking and theology around
creation and almost had to go back and
learn like what's it like to relate to
things as holy again because in the last
500 years with the rise of science
technology we got all kind of swept
along with you know that view that our
imaginations were kind of we did start
to see things just machines and you know
like sorry we just how think of it and
uh like I think for example in
indigenous culture you know they didn't
um view you know killing a buffalo was
not turning off power to the meat
machine. You see what I'm saying? Like
it was sacred and they knew they had to
do it for life to to eat to make it
right. So they would kill but it was
almost treated in this kind of very holy
way. you know there was like a some
ritual around it and a kind of even
prayers and such I think actually this
is the origin of like praying before
meals which again a lot of us have lost
but I wonder if we can this can help us
rediscover that where there's a kind of
gratitude for this precious thing that
had to give its life for my life you
know there's that's like a completely
different
imagination than I don't know where this
came from and I don't want to know don't
show me the YouTube video you know what
I mean like That's this is this is but
this is kind of our relationship um to
so much of the the natural world. So I
think you know pay attention as best you
can. I know we're all busy and we're
stressed out and all the things you know
so but but still as best you can pay
attention to things like where your food
comes from and um even consider going
like vegetarian or eating less meat if
you can. I mean, think of it. For the
first time in human history, we can
actually get all the calories we need
without having to kill things with like
central nervous systems. That's it's
kind of an amazing thing. Um, and but
it's it's amazing how this isn't on
Christians radars. It doesn't seem to
me, at least in like a a broad way. Uh,
third, I've kind of already named this
one, but I and all creatures are never
far from God. To exist as a being is to
arise from the source of all being.
I think when I talk with folks at at the
table, I often hear, "I just feel so far
from God. I just feel so distant from
God." I wonder if some of this could be
if we had a different theological
imagination, something more sacramental
where it wasn't like, well, I need like
some sort of I don't know like whisbang
experience of God or then I would know,
you know, instead of starting to just
treat everything as kind of a
participant, a pointer to, you know, the
smile of your child or any child, you
know, the the beautiful light of the
candle
um the the solidity of the chair. It's
just like all grace, God's grace, God's
presence, God's love for you, just
existence itself, being
[Music]
itself, it's nice to be alive, you know,
like there's just that and that's we
start to get this um yeah, more of a
sense of connection to to God again. Um
fourth and finally, the sacraments and
liturgy of the church. Um so things like
of course communion, music, baptism,
prayer again are not boundaries on God
but jumping off points to help us see
all life and creation as
sacramental. And uh I think the
Christian mystics, they really got this
point. St. Francis of Aisi for example
um didn't see the moon and just be like
oh interesting the moon you know for him
it was like brother moon you know and
this the sun was sister son and the
birds are like his his like friends and
you know there's this sense of intimacy
and connection to all things and I I I
think oh how wonderful would it be if
just like all Christians started to
think in this way you know with that
sense of intimacy and uh connection and
oneness to to all things. So I'll close
with this quote. This is uh from the
brothers Kamazoff which I'm obligated to
quote at least twice a year, preferably
four or five times a year in every
sermon if I can. I love this novel. This
is from a monk in that story named
Father Zasima, a Christian monk. And he
says this, "My brother asked the birds
to forgive him." That sounds senseless,
but it is
right. For all is like an ocean. All is
flowing and blending. A touch in one
place sets up movement at the other end
of the earth. It may be senseless to beg
forgiveness of the birds. Oh, but birds
would be happier at your side. A little
happier anyway. and children and all
animals. If you were nobler than you are
now, it's like an ocean, I tell
you. Then you would pray to the birds,
too, consumed by an all embracing love
in a sort of transport and pray that
they too will forgive you your
sin. Treasure this
ecstasy, however senseless it may seem
to men.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit.
Amen. So on the night Jesus was
betrayed, he had one final meal with his
disciples. And at that meal, he held up
a loaf of bread and he broke it. And he
said, "Take it and eat. This is my body.
It's broken for you." And he held him a
cup of wine. He said, "Take this and
drink. This is my blood. It's shed for
you. Whenever you eat this bread,
whenever you drink this cup, remember
me. So, as we come forward tonight, we
participate in this sacrament, this this
bread and wine, which both allows us to
participate in it, but also points us
beyond itself to to the God who is
father, son, and holy spirit. So, the
way we'll participate in communion
tonight is we'll just go rowby row.
We'll start here at the front. We'll
just form a line right here in the
middle and kind of as one row finishes
the next one can get up and uh jump into
the line. If uh you should know we
practice what's called an open table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
want to participate then you're free to
do that regardless of your theology or
denominational background or whatever.
Um at the same time if you don't want to
do if you don't want to participate
that's you know that's okay too. You
should know the red is wine the white is
grape juice and then finally you can
just partake however you'd like. Some
folks like to come forward and move.
Some like to return to their seats and
partake. Or you could take immediately.
But no one will lead you through the
exact moment of taking the elements. So
this is the table not of the church but
of the Lord. And it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come. You who
have much faith and you who have little.
You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long and you who've
tried to
follow and you who have failed,
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
When you're ready, if you guys would
stand with us, we're going to circle
back around to so Will I. And let's um
sing these words and be mindful of how
we are all a part of this creative work
that God is doing in us and through us
and with us.
As you
speak, a h 100 billion creatures catch
your breath,
evolving in pursuit of what you say.
If it all reveals your nature so
I can see your heart and everything you
say. Every pain and sky a canvas for
your face.
If creation still obeys you, so will
I. So alive.
your
[Music]
life. If the stars were made to worship,
so
light. If the mountains bow in
reverence, so will
thou. If the oions roar your greatness,
so will
I. For if
everything exists to lift you
high, so
alive. If the wind goes where you send
it so
light. If the rocks crown inside so
light. If the sun of all our praises
still fall shine.
will see again a 100 million times.
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh, thanks everyone so much for joining
us this evening. Um, if you are new,
we'd love for you to fill out a visitor
card for us. There's some over at this
table here to my left, or you can also
scan the QR code that's up behind me,
and you can fill out an online visitor
card. If you call the table home, but
you don't currently serve on a ministry
team, we'd love to have you try one out.
Our tech team, our kids ministry, and
our host team are currently in the most
need. So you can fill out a card also on
the table or scan the QR code and sign
up again. Also by scanning that QR code,
you'll be able to see all the exciting
things we have coming up. We have our
Dallas Pride booth, our summer kids
camp, and also the wheelchair ramp team.
So go ahead and scan the QR code and
sign up and find out more information
there. Also, don't forget, join us at
Hat Creek immediately following this.
I'll be there with my family, so I look
forward to seeing some of you
there. Generosity is a key aspect of a
life of adoration and worship. If the
table is your church home, then we
invite you to scan the QR code and you
can give financially or you can also
visit the
tabletx.org. All right, let me send you
into this week with a blessing.
You can hold out your hands in a posture
to receive or you can simply just open
your heart to these
[Music]
words. You are a child of
God. You are a child of
God. This is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day.
So, as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between, go and be
filled with the assurance that you are
loved, you are worthy, and you are
accepted just as you are. And go filled
with the Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
into contact with. Be blessed. We'll see
you here next Sunday.
[Music]
As you
speak, 100 billion failures
[Music]
disappear. Will you lost your life so I
can find
it? If you left the grave behind me so
alive. I can see your heart and
everything you've
done. Every
part of love.
If you gladly chose surren
[Music]
My ears went out.
Oh no.